that FTX sex tape would be disgusting  yes I agree they weren't like giving it  yeah I mean it's all like a bunch of  like amphetamineed up Engineers that  haven't seen the sun yeah in like weeks  they're messed up like Sam had a  gigantic dick not even that he he might  have just been average but he might have  just been like he might have had Rhythm  doubt it  It's probably hard to be rhythmic on  amphetamines yeah probably doing crazy  [ __ ] yeah like can't focus on the sex  yeah they need stuff and thinking about  options like short my tether yeah short  my tether I was I was picturing more  scary stuff like just drawing symbols on  the wall  they're coming  naked with a boner talking about kpis  all of a sudden yeah